in kiev ukraine lives an mma fighter
named yuri boyka he is the best fighter
in europe and has gained the title of
undisputed one evening boyka is fighting
in an illegal match held in an
underground arena as the crowd cheers he
doesn't let the opponent get a single
hit on him after a brief one-sided fight
he kicks the opponent in midair and
knocks him out the scene changes to a
maximum security prison in russia the
inmates participate in fights for the
guards and the wardens entertainment
such matches are seemingly friendly to
the outside world but can get very
violent with the right participants the
deadliest prisoner of all time is a
beast of a man named koshmar he is so
aggressive that the guards have to chain
his limbs and close his mouth to ensure
he won't hurt anyone outside the ring
koshmar's opponent is half his size and
can hardly land a punch on him he slams
the man to the ground breaking his neck
before proceeding to punch him in the
face the fight only stops when his face
is deformed and covered in blood koshmar
is known for killing every opponent he
fights against showing them no mercy he
is more of a monster than a human and
has no guilt for killing so many people
unlike him boyka is a good man outside
of the ring he hasn't had a great life
as he was imprisoned for several years
and is a wanted criminal in russia but
he has been able to put his past aside
and is trying to be a better person he
even helps the church in kiev and is
always doing charity work one day a
priest tells him that he should consider
choosing another profession the priest
has always supported boyka's passion
hence the comment comes off as a shock
to the fighter boyka replies that his
talent is a gift from god and he is not
willing to stop using it he wants to
fight as a professional and not in an
illegal environment anymore in the
afternoon boycha is approached by his
manager who reveals that he can finally
compete legally in legitimate mma
matches the european fighting tournament
happening in budapest has allowed him to
take part in the competition if he wins
a qualifying match then comes the day of
the qualification match since it is one
of the most important fights of boyco's
life he is ready to give it all his
opponent is a russian man named victor
the match begins and boyka lands the
first effective kick in the first few
minutes he shows his defending skills
deflecting every single attack made on
him as victor gets more frustrated it is
easier for boyka to make an attack the
judges on the sidelines are already
impressed so when he knocks victor out
with a knee to his jaw it confirms his
qualification everyone thinks the match
is over but victor surprises them by
getting up seconds later he is knocked
down a second time but he refuses to
accept defeat by now boyka is frustrated
so he lands a third punch on victor's
face knocking him senseless after the
win the organizers invite boyka to
budapest to fight in the league which
will open many doors of opportunities
for him the manager gives boyka a bundle
of money asking him to train hard
because the next match is in two weeks
while leaving boyka sees that victor is
in critical condition he feels guilty
for hurting him that bad and would have
never done it if he had given up after
the first knockout boyka remembers the
priest's advice and praise for victor's
fast recovery at night he wakes up to a
nightmare of him killing an opponent in
the ring the very next morning he goes
to the manager and inquires about victor
to his shock he is told that victor died
last night in the hospital they had
signed a pre-match contract so the blame
falls on nobody however in his heart
boycha knows that he is the cause of the
death i mean obviously upon being asked
about victor's family the manager gives
him a bag that belonged to him inside it
boyka finds a letter from victor's wife
and their picture together in reading
the letter he can feel the pain his wife
must have gone through when she found
out about his death right then boyka
decides to apologize to her and make
sure she is not facing any problems in
life he knows that his crime will not be
forgiven even then but he doesn't want
to run away from the path of redemption
boycott tells the manager about his wish
to go to russia to meet victor's wife
but the guy is extremely against the
idea boyka is still a criminal in russia
and will be imprisoned if found by the
authorities he will have to make a fake
passport which is a huge risk now that
he is so close to being a legitimate mma
fighter boyka understands the
consequences but is adamant about his
decision in the following scene we are
introduced to victor's wife alma who is
at his funeral after his death she is
alone in life and has no one to turn to
on top of that she and victor are
indebted to a crime boss named zurab he
comes to the funeral and suggests alma
be his mistress to pay off her debt alma
is disgusted by his presence but she is
careful not to make him mad she simply
replies that she will rather work hard
and pay him an installment alma owns and
lives in a community center she and
victor built it with the money they
borrowed from zurab the place is home to
many orphans and people who are in need
on arriving in russia boyka goes to meet
her but notices her being taken away in
a black car by a bunch of men it turns
out that she works as a waitress in
zurab's underground fighting club he is
very protective of her and treats her
like his property later that day boyka
goes to the fight club and finds alma
when he tries talking to her zourab's
people stop him and escort him outside
boyco wants to avoid fighting hence he
politely asks them what time she will
get off work the gangsters attack him at
the question but are in turn taught a
lesson for messing with a professional
fighter zurab sees boyka fight and is
impressed by his skills he has been
needing a good martial artist in his
club and wants to hire boyka however the
man argues that he is not here to
participate in fights he simply wants to
meet the girl zurab offers to talk to
alma on his behalf refusing to let him
meet her but boyka yet again disagrees
with him and walks away after he is out
of sight zurab asks his people to keep
an eye on him the following day boyka
manages to sneak into the community
center and meet alma he gives her
victor's letter and asks her if she is
being forced to work at the fight club
alma replies that she would like to work
somewhere else but is bound by the dead
she then reads the letter and asks him
if he saw her husband's last fight boyka
comes clean admitting that he was the
last person victor fought he tries
explaining that the death was an
accident but alma refuses to listen to
her husband's killer following the
interaction boyka goes to zurab and
agrees to fight for him however in turn
he will have to forget all of alma's
death the deal is that boyca has to win
three matches against the opponent of
zurab's choice the gangster also
promises to keep him safe from the
police and authorities since he knows he
got into russia using a fake passport
the next day alma meets boyka to tell
him she doesn't need his pity she wants
him to return home but boyka insists he
is doing this for his own satisfaction
after that he goes to a local gym to
train for the matches but is bullied by
a man when the guy keeps on poking him
boyka slams him down with a single kick
then comes the day of the first fight
boyka goes against a local fighter in an
easy match the rival manages to land a
few weak kicks but is proven to be weak
in front of someone as good as boyka he
manages to knock him down and is about
to throw the last punch but stops midway
to his relief the opponent accepts
defeat so he doesn't have to hurt him
further after the fight alma serves some
drinks boyka asks her if she is familiar
with a nice local gym because the one he
is going to right now doesn't live up to
his standards alma thinks about it for a
while before inviting him to use the gym
in her community center he trains there
for the next few days and ultimately
alma gets used to his presence boyka's
next match is a two versus one against a
pair of brothers he is shocked because
he was never told about these rules
zurab boasts that it is his arena and
the fighters have to play by the rules
the match begins and boika struggles to
defend against both brothers at the same
time when he tries to fight one the
other attacks making it hard for him to
focus still he manages to push one away
and knock the other one down in the
seconds they take to recover it is an
equal match until boyka is kicked in his
already injured lower back the pain is
unbearable until he sees alma in the
audience and continues fighting after
that he kicks both their asses and
scores a double knockout the crowd
erupts into cheers as no one had thought
he would win this match as well the next
day zurab goes to meet alma and tries to
flirt with her when she deflects his
advances he accuses her of sleeping with
boyka he also riles her up claiming that
her husband's death wasn't accidental
and that boycott meant to kill him alma
pretends to not believe him but the
comment bothers her meanwhile boyka's
manager from ukraine calls him back
immediately because he has a press
meeting for the fight in budapest boyka
asks him to postpone it since he only
has one last fight to win upon reaching
his room he finds alma waiting for him
she urges him to tell the truth about
her husband's death and boyka starts
telling her about all the hardships he
has faced in life he reveals that the
first half of his life was filled with
misery and the match against victor was
his only chance at getting a better life
he gave it all and won but victor's
death took away a bigger part of him he
knows that accepting his help is very
difficult for alma but he begs her to
let him do what he has to at night for
the final match boyka goes against igor
zurab's best fighter who has been
mocking boyka since the day he arrived
igor is especially furious at boyka
because he has a threat to his position
in the gang he takes all his frustration
out and showers him with repeated
attacks he manages to put up a tough
fight making boyka's lower back his main
target but the direction of the fight
changes when boyka lands a double midair
kick on him following that he beats igor
black and blue making him bleed
profusely until he passes out with this
he wins the entire tournament and alma's
debt is paid however zureb has already
predicted the outcome and prepared for
it he stops boyka and reveals that he
has to fight one last man for their deal
to be over boyka only has a few hours
before his meeting in budapest which is
very crucial for his career but he
doesn't want to leave without saving
alma hence he asks the manager to wait
until the next morning and gets ready to
fight the final champion the opponent is
koshmar the beast who has fought and
killed all of his opponents in the
russian prison he is brought into the
arena in chains because of his violent
nature the fight starts but boyka is
already too tired he tries his best but
his attacks seem to do koshmar little to
no harm because of his physique the
beast lands several punches on him
before kicking him in the jaw boyka
falls down because of the impact and has
a hard time standing back up seconds
before losing the fight he gathers
strength and stands up again but is
again slammed to the floor when koshmar
is almost sure that he is one boyka
takes him by surprise and pushes him
back with a kick after that the fight
tilts to his side he holds the beast in
an arm lock breaking his right arm
before kicking him out of the ring with
this he finally wins the match but zurab
is still not ready to let go of alma he
makes his minion attack boyka while he
tries to run away with the girl boyka is
on the ground at his lowest when he sees
alma being pulled outside with renewed
motivation and anger he attacks the
guards and kills them all at last he
gets his hands on zurab and tackles him
to the ground boika is shot in the
process but his pain is overshadowed by
his anger eventually zureb is strangled
to death alma tries to help boyka but he
stops her asking her if he has her
forgiveness some time later the police
arrive and arrest him before being
pulled away he again inquires if she
forgives him but alma doesn't give him a
reply then boyka is put back into a
russian prison a month later alma comes
to visit him and tells him that he is
forgiven boika is relieved for the first
time in months even though his plan to
become a professional fighter failed in
the last scene we see him fighting in
the prisons arena continuing to hold the
title of the undisputed subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching